welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss in Ant-Man the WASP Quantum Mania
is creating new questions of logic and
physics that will not be able to be
settled by putting Quantum in front of
everything we're now in our final throws
to the film's marketing life cycle with
daily promos teasing different Snippets
of the movie some more spoilery than
others but thankfully for this movie
nothing really that earlier trailers
haven't shown us but one recurring Focus
has been on giant Scott rampaging
through the quantum realm leading to the
question if the quantum realm is located
between atoms accessed by shrinky
smaller and smaller and smaller how is
Scott able to resize to be larger
relative to this Quantum realm City so
easily is he able to control his
resizing by just the tiniest increments
like to enlarge by point zero zero one
nanometer this is resizing proportional
to the size of whatever his current
surroundings are if he were to hold the
resizing button for too long would he
grow too big and Crush these cities why
is it Marvel's Ant-Man movies that
create the biggest plot holes well I'm
gonna break down quantumania's New
pintech Logic because actually the
answer to this question takes us to even
crazier places and speaking of going to
crazier places a reminder to subscribe
to our new channel the Deep dive where
you'll be able to see my live breakdown
of quantumania in the morning of
February 17th ask me all your questions
in real time as I take you behind the
scenes of my Insanity okay in the past
week we got a new quantumania promo that
showed Scott going bold Godzilla on the
quantum realm City
Oh Our Big Boys mad another promo showed
Scott sizing up Suddenly to Grapple with
a glowing orb floating toward him and
Cassie and later shots in that trailer
show Scott initially falling into the
quantum realm tapping in its chest like
Iron Man to activate a suit and then
immediately grow to Giant side so that
he could cushion his own ball and land
on his feet now we know for the very
first trailer that Scott grows to giant
size while he's in this Quantum realm
and he faces Kang's Fleet however we've
also seen a shot of Scott in a different
part of the quantum realm it seems where
Apparently one of his Schrodinger
variants makes the mistake of growing to
giant size and that's what causes him to
unravel so for some reason in that part
of the quantum realm resizing is
impossible or just deadly either way
everything is in and consistent I was
just out of the country of my honeymoon
and I went on Netflix over there and I
was shocked to see all the stuff that
normally is there in American Netflix
but not where I was that's why it's so
important to use nordvpn with nordvpn I
could switch my virtual location on my
device with one click letting me access
streaming services from over 60
countries at no extra cost this opens up
a smorgasbord of stuff to watch that I
wouldn't be able to access without
nordvpn nordvpn is also the fastest VPN
out there so you won't have to sacrifice
speed for sake of your shows it's what
we use at new Rockstar's offices let me
tell you it's fast for the price of just
one cup of coffee a month I get to have
premium cyber security on six devices
and gain access to streaming services
from over 60 countries at no extra cost
it's also available on every platform to
grab your exclusive nordvpn deal go to
nordvpn.com new rockstars to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift nordvpn is a 30 day money
back guarantee so you can try nordvp and
completely risk-free just click the link
in the description to get started we
should pause here to focus on the fact
that Scott has a suit with a chess
button completely new for him something
closer to the nanotechnology we saw Tony
Stark wearing under his clothes like the
mark 50's suit in Avengers Infinity War
he could just kind of tap it and go
right in the middle of the street
previously Scott has always had to
awkwardly slowly suit up in that
motorcycle jump soon it wasn't
convenient at all clearly now it has
been upgraded so in the time since
Avengers end game the PIM Family has
been busy so the simplest explanation
for how Scott is able to resize so
effectively on a subatomic level is that
the quantum realm isn't just the loose
space between atoms of our universe it's
its own separate realm and the portal to
this realm can only be accessed by
shrinking to a subatomic scale like
imagine going from one large room that
we're in right now to another large room
that's right beside us but the door to
that room is really really really small
come on in it's your master bedroom ow
my nose in 2018's Ant-Man the WASP when
Hank Pym enters the quantum realm we
clearly see it passing through some
barrier membrane which bends from the
momentum of the ship and then pierces to
let him through and seals after he
passes so once you're on the other side
of that door you're in a new realm and
you can grow and Shrink as you normally
would when you're in that realm though
obviously once you're in this realm the
topography and the physics of it have
their own surreal qualities actually the
acid trip that was a Quantum realm in
the 2018 film seems to now have a more
tangible structure there's Flora there's
fauna there's civilizations with bars
and organized militaries so clearly
gravity and breathable air must exist
also we know that growing and shrinking
must be possible from the 2018 film
remember when Hank and Janet left the
quantum realm in that shuttle the
shuttle began to grow a few sizes as it
was still on its way out of the quantum
realm really all this brings up the
mystery of the general layout in the map
of the Multiverse in the MCU and how
Realms like the quantum realm fit in
universes like the alternate universes
we saw in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse Madness where is everything
the movie everything everywhere all at
once depicted its Multiverse is a plane
of bagels that can get linked together
in a chain or slingshotted around each
other like pinballs so is it that hard
for the MCU to come up with its own
visual aid it seems like every movie
every Disney Plus show are coming up
with their own way to try to explain it
and they're all really bad at it and
then in this movie Janet describes the
quantum realm as the secret Universe
beneath ours okay okay beneath got it
but is beneath really the best way to
describe where it is directionally like
isn't it really between ours or inside
of ours or like metaphysically
catacorner to ours saying the quantum
realm is beneath us it's like saying
Hell is beneath us which is silly hell
is there something Fisto made up to
scare kids nothing's worse than the
nightmare of existence we're living in
right now all of this is to say I think
this movie is going to require us to
bend our linear understanding of space
and instead see Dimensions as Shadow
Realms that are layered on top of of our
own and then also like inside of our own
like filters we'd be able to see with
just the right lens and pin particles
are the key to all of it they allow for
Dimension hopping because when you
shrink down subatomic the laws of
physics no longer apply and you get into
quantum mechanics which operate on their
own theoretical rules so if shrinking
from our normal plane of existence to a
subatomic scale allows access to the
quantum realm a separate Dimension
shrinking between the atoms of that
Dimension may allow Scott to access an
even deeper Dimension and that could be
where we see Scott and his Schrodinger
variants in the trailer footage and at
that level resizing just isn't possible
you're not even a physical entity at
that point you're just like a
hypothetical possibility of an entity
like the abstract thought section of the
Mind in Pixar's Inside Out or the limbo
layer of Christopher Nolan's Inception
this is really the darkest most
confusing bit of Despair for the hero
where nothing really makes sense it's
also kind of like the tesser X sequence
in interstellar we're literally in a
giant plot hole here and the way you get
out of it is some kind of clever
repositioning of things that makes sense
an emotional way in Scott's case using
the logic of his own nature an Ant-Man
and thus he in his variants stack the
way ants do so the pin particle isn't
just the key to the Gateway of the
quantum realm it's also the ticket to
the Nexus Forge of the Multiverse
shrinking ladies and gents what was once
the campus visual joke of the MCU is now
the scariest thought experiment that's
being put into practice no wonder why
Kang once Ant-Man more than any other
Avenger a reminder to subscribe to our
new channel the Deep dive launching
February 17th and hey you may have
noticed me wearing this new shirt this
is actually a custom shirt inspired by
Ant-Man the Watson Mania that you could
get at our merch store
nerdriot.shop you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter follow me
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]